rappelons un plan une plante aux essais
quoi et on reçoit le patron ce soir
c'est bien
franchement j'aime assez le patron c'est
dans l'ailé michel drucker et
annulations merci d'être avec nous et
michel comment ça va très bien je crois
que je vais partir tout ce soir ce mardi
à bosser mon émission de demain ouais
j'ai fait une fois pardon un pc michel a
fixé c'est pas un bus c'est un plan que
michel la veille de mon émission landes
majeures ne retournent quoi à planquer
apc interne à flot un plan une à planter
et fait quoi michel ses comptes en
couche avec une personne dont on ne
connaît pas le prénom alors toiture
timber la peau du touch pro sont indoor
kinder c'est pas les gens de recherche
la vie moi à oui à darwin de beaucoup
tout ça suffit maintenant si je parlais
des gages à faire vous êtes sur quoi
rester calmes michel ce que c'est j'ai
découvert un truc soit oui attendus des
plans culture tout ça mais c'est quoi
points des leaders c'est quoi c'est un
site vous mettez votre photo et puis il
ya les garçons qui sont disponibles le
plus près de vous nos catalogues
voilà maintenant michel essais par
géolocalisation là c'est à dire que
voilà il ya quelqu'un parle donc voilà
c'est que j'en ai à un moment il faut
mettre votre top va arriver dans sa
gamme
on est à l'aise je ne supporte pas
embrassés dans notre métier qui dit il
est bon ton de taille et b des costards
ne jamais dire à quelqu'un tu sais ce
que tu fais bien mais toujours des
flingues et le nombre de gens dans les
premières années de la carrière de tvnp
et cousins nunaat avec sa est d'accord
et puis ceux qui misaient ça gênait
voyez venir faire leur promo et quand
j'ai vu qu'il y avait tout le monde avec
depardieu
tout le monde est venu chez lui j'ai
trouvé ça un peu gonflé quand même ce
qui me déplaît beaucoup dans notre
métier c'est des gens qui viennent faire
leur promo qui viennent vent hors soupes
chez nous et on va je prends l'avant
bien la soupe et qui ne démolisse une
fois qu'ils ont tourné la porte du
studio ça c'est pas bien dans ce cas il
faut pas venir
merci michel en tout cas une fois michel
a été vexé par une phrase de johnny sur
son corps il lui a dit tu fais beaucoup
de ce beaucoup de sport
mais ça se voit pas beaucoup à la télé
non il m'a dit autre chose d'inédit
il m'a dit tu sais que tu encore morale
pour ton âge 10 est gentil on a le même
âge et mener mais quel est ton secret
magie des coups de génie tu sais bien je
je je je dors comme il faut je fais du
sport je vais voir des médecins je suis
hypocondriaque je travaille beaucoup sur
pas le soir c'est la même faim depuis
plus de 40 ans et là il m'a dit qu'elle
vit de campath
et une anecdote michel taly qu'une seule
fois en boîte nantes amis et avec
l'autre françois gainsbourg exactement
il paraît qu'il est plein fille non mais
les boîtes de nuit j allais jamais fallu
une fois dans ma vie c'est chez régine
voilà je suis pour une pénurie
et moi je suis arrivé à 10h c'est fermé
j'ai dû me tromper luigi me ça ouvre à
quelle heure et claude françois et 15
lots sont arrivés à minuit mais je sais
par minute et la première réflexion que
j'ai fait on en reprend j'ai appelé jean
génie il ya un courant d'air
je vais avoir fait prendre froid là que
ça kim qui me préoccupe et mon père
m'avait dit à l'époque ne va pas dans
une boîte de nuit où la légende le froid
tu vas attraper une pneumonie et
désagréable me présente deux mannequins
absolument incroyable qui viennent vers
moi et moi j'étais comme ça non il
disait je crois que j'attrape matin je
rentrais chez moi j'habite ici je suis à
la pharmacie j'ai pris une verveine me
suis couché voilà ma première soirée en
boîte il n'y aurait plus jamais non
jamais retournement nancy une fois dans
une boîte d une bad as me spéciale le
queens puis celle d'honneur de dalida
ah oui leur landau qui m'a amené au
queen ah oui et j'ai pas vu beaucoup de
filles et vous avez vu l espèce de filet
au plafond on peut se pendre et quand on
a bien su donner à l'enfant
[Musique]